[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford making an impact through music
meet eitan pered an israeli singer and
songwriter
ayton is an american american-born and
raised israeli singer and songwriter
who composes and sings in arabic hebrew
and english together
after being accepted to the prominent
gilgalats playlist his first song out
where are the days went viral and has
passed 1 million views on youtube and
currently has over one million streams
across digital streaming platforms like
apple music and spotify
he believes that learning each other's
language is the key to emotional
connection
and mutual understanding of perspective
and culture either
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great what a pleasure to be here
what a great honor it is my honor to
have you here i had your sister on the
show about 200 episodes ago i am
so excited and humbled to have the
pellet family here
and there are a few members that i'm
missing but the talk we're going to have
is so different
than than previous episodes i'm
incredibly excited for this one because
we're going to talk about culture and
we're going to talk about compassion and
true understanding through language and
through
our cultures i got introduced to your
work
when i fell in love with your song were
the days out of the million views more
than a million views you have i think
i'm like 900
000 of those and i can pretty much sing
it with you and a little teaser i'm
going to ask you to sing it soon
but but it's really phenomenal and i and
i can't wait to hear a little bit about
your journey all the way from being an
arabic commander and in in in the
all the way to your now perspective as a
singer songwriter and where you're
headed so i talked enough
eitan tell me a little bit about
yourself and and where do you come from
and what do you do
all right thank you so much i'm ethan
i'm 24 years old uh
i'm i'm from america originally from
boston
there i was born and raised and i moved
i had a bit of a period where i moved in
between america and israel when i was a
kid but
in seventh grade i kind of settled here
in israel with my whole family in ranana
and in the army i was uh before the army
actually
now this is a world that we could
obviously indulge in conversation and
many different topics i did a metric now
it's a pre-army like leadership program
and after that in the army i served as a
commander
in shmoni matam a200 intelligence ivf
unit where i was
doing arabic i had a half a year
intensive
arabic course and then started my job
ended up as a commander had an amazing
time probably one of the most like
influential stops uh so far in my life
after that i was offered to stay in the
field of security and i was thinking
about it for a while i mean i'm the kind
of person that really
anything i'm doing i'm 100 in it and i
think that's what i'm about to do for
the rest of my life and then i'm just
uh i kind of want to go to the next stop
and connect something else
so um i towards the end of my service i
decided to move
i kind of had this this thought in my
head this um like i'm always searching
for meaning
and i had this thought run through my
head thinking you know i think in israel
people that love arabic and are
and are i i'm a person like that i love
arabic it's a
language that intrigues me and i
everything about it i really really love
it
and i think that many of those people
are put into
fields of security um and they're those
minds are kind of used for that
and i kind of feel like in israel was
lacking at that point i felt like it was
lacking an education
uh and something else like to kind of
move that passion of mine towards
education
so i moved totally changed everything i
was planning i moved to julie's which
was a drew's village
in the galileo maravi in the north and i
served as a
emerging councillor i lived there um
with about 15 boys it was all boy
and it was super interesting i mean it's
just like drews and jewish people
the mix clash between cultures and
living together and
getting to know israeli society together
was awesome and
then i traveled south america i love
traveling i love voice you know just
i'm very curious person i like to see
the world and traveling i just had this
you know
i mean have you traveled uh michael you
traveled a little in the world i i got
to travel a little bit i haven't been to
i think south america yet properly but i
think that one of the things that i'm
inspired by truly but what you're saying
is is this
passion this curiousness for for
cultures and for
truly understanding the other that it's
not just about
learning arabic and being able to you
know understand the other language
it's about the culture it's about you
know going to being with 15 others and
being in the jewish community and
and really assimilating and i think that
you know your work also through the song
where are the days you know when i'm
when i'm hearing it
when i'm when i'm singing one of the
most beautiful things that that i have
to point out
off the bat is that you're speaking
three different you're singing in three
different languages the song
and there's so many different questions
that i want to ask i want to i want us
to talk about
you know where does this come from this
curiosity and this humbleness to go and
be open perspectives i want to talk
about the meaning of the song and where
you're headed now with your creative
means
to make an impact and move the needle
but before all that eitan i
i have to owe it to myself and whoever
is listening to this
uh we need to we need to perform the
song because i think that
the power that goes through it it really
embodies then
the journey that you're on so please
awesome i mean i'm i think that would be
awesome because i don't always
articulate myself as
well as i want to with words but through
music i always feel like it's
you know i love it that's what i can
express best so let's do it
all right i'm just gonna i'm singing a
little bit sideways
just so perfect here we go
all right let's do it
[Music]
let's go take it back
to that place where it's okay to make
mistakes
the sun is setting getting late
help it change the path she takes
but girl don't you do that don't you do
that don't you do that
and i wanna make it right wanna stand
and face your fate wanna make it through
the night fear is driving me insane so
girl don't you do that don't you do that
don't you do that take her
back to the days where we left out
through
the nights together turn around to show
your face
it's okay to not be okay
and i know deep inside
emotions trying to hide
[Music]
where are the days where are the days
where are
the days smile
on your face
[Music]
[Applause]
i
need your
[Music]
[Applause]
i need your
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
wow dude
unbelievable it's the power of it
and the emotions i can't even articulate
eitan thank you for sharing your gift
with me in in these
four very short but you know endless
minutes they're
just beautiful walk me through the back
where when do you decide
that you're going to be a song writer
and singer
i mean i used to be like the shyest kid
i was just like sitting now i've always
loved singing and songwriting but
i mean i've only been doing music for
like you know kind of like
showing people music and for maybe two
years you know like
three years i was always in my room yeah
i always meet wow i'm like like i'm in
the music industry here now like you
know meeting all these people it's a
small industry so i mean lots of people
are
surprised like i think they've been
doing it for so long but no
only two years i've been doing music um
and uh
the decision was when i traveled i mean
you know it's just like any it's a
childhood dream i kind of i found this
slogan that um from this youtube channel
i came across
called yes theory that they have a
channel and their
their concept is seek discomfort you
know like try and you know find those
discomforting moments and
go towards those and that kind of opened
my mind up and
during my traveling which is obviously a
lot of seeking discomfort
i kind of came to that decision i was
like you know what i've always wanted to
give music a try i've always had that
dream
and uh and i just i came back from my
trip i was like i'm going for it and i
just went for it and the song
specifically where are the days it's not
an ordinary song you're not an
ordinary songwriter and singer and the
song itself
is very very special tell me about the
creation behind it specifically
well i think in general when i write
songs i think it's
where i express myself best and usually
i don't i think unlike different songs
where a lot of songs are written
about and i think almost time to write
about love but it's not romantic love
so like my it's all it's a kind of way
to express myself to somebody that i
care about
so i'm not gonna like share who this
person is just to keep their privacy but
i wrote the song about someone i really
really care about
who was going through a really hard time
and with kind of
depression and maybe even a bit of
suicidal thoughts and whatnot and i just
couldn't find my way to express what i
was feeling toward like tell the person
to try and
empathize with them and i just put it
all into the song and uh
i think it's the fastest song i've ever
written i know like i had no idea what i
was doing at the time like i think
now i'm always because i write songs now
for tv shows and all kinds of things and
now
i'm really like uh meticulous and i try
and like you know
calculate everything went on this song
just kind of pour out and
pour it out of me i had no idea how and
honest hard for me to explain a bit how
but they're
that's part of the magic i'm listening
to this i'm sitting here and i'm i'm
feeling the energy both in the in the
beautiful music video which is
you know there's nothing fancy it's you
singing
showing your emotions here you know i
believe it i can see
i can see how it just comes out of you
yeah definitely i will say one thing
that was important for me in the song
was uh i mean it's obviously something
calculated to make a song in three
languages so like
every part i feel like i express first
of all i think every language
brings out a different side of me which
is something like i've had so many
people send me messages after the song
like saying oh you should only do music
in the arabic or only doing english
you're only doing you
know like which is for me that's a great
response because i feel like everybody
connects a different part of the song
and or like if maybe i portray or give
out a different emotion
through every language which is very
nice and but uh it was important for me
rhythm wise with the music i mean to
make
everything sit kind of on the same
rhythm because i mean i've even had some
people that listen to the song
that either they learn the arabic really
quickly and they never knew arabic in
their life or they didn't even realize
there's arabic i've had people not even
realize that there's arabic in the song
because it's just like sounds
very like equal the english and the
arabic and i think and
that's my kind of way to get people to
and open their minds up towards the
language and also
kind of memorize suddenly like somebody
i have so many friends there's only
people that know all the arabic by heart
and they have like you know suddenly
they
they know like 200 words in arabic and
within like a few minutes
unbelievable so tell me a little bit
about
30 000 feet in the air bigger picture
language culture you know you're talking
here it's it's
not an accident it's like there's hebrew
there's english there's arabic
there's a lot of contestion you know
when you look at these three cultures
put in the same room
what is where do you see yourself in
this you know
epicenter in in in this whole context
because you are taking a stance you are
doing something
that is that is bound to change the
needle
my my stance is like i mean obviously i
have
my opinions and whatnot which have to do
with
with this whole issue or whole topic but
i'm a very emotional person and i really
feel like at the end of the day
you know as hippie as it sounds we're
all human and what makes us human and
that emotion
it connects us much stronger than
anything else that i can
that i can do and i get that i see that
it works i get
responses from people that are arab and
jewish and i just see that people right
connect to the same emotion you know
just the same things
and that and i think that what make you
know it's that classic
bridging between people through what
makes us common and what makes us human
which is emotion so obviously a topic
like
um let's say for example not everybody
realizes this song is about let's say
depression or whatnot i mean you could
also take it which is beautiful music
you can take it to your own world
right and i wouldn't but i do get
responses that are very specific from
people that are going through those hard
times that are also arab and also jewish
and um and that's just i mean that's
that speaks louder than what i can say
i i love that take me back a little bit
to your experiences with the mechanic
and the idf and your upbringing because
what i'm curious about
is not only you know what happens now
moving forward i'm curious about
what brought you here what what what
gave you this you know this empathy and
this
you know this open-mindedness to go and
explore these different cultures what do
you attribute that to
i definitely attribute that to my
parents my parents gave me the best
education i could wish for i really
i admire my parents both my parents are
our professors
they they teach here in uh here in
israel and i got a really open-minded
education and it's like i find myself
very easily
putting myself in somebody else's shoes
or i don't know just like
that it's something that uh that i gotta
credit to them
for sure that's the most and
and they let me i mean it's not it's not
that obvious i can give you like an
example like i'm doing music now
which i mean not every parent is so
excited when their kid like you know
suddenly decides to
start doing music right i mean it's not
a and my parents are so supportive and
and i definitely accredit them that kind
of open-mindedness that i
that i've had or that i have towards
that
you know i think i was really educated
george if i love something and
passionate about something just
do it so so what gets you going right
now so you wake up in the morning
you're an upcoming singer songwriter
you're building yourself up now you're
getting into this network
i mean literally this has happened now i
mean this song is out from may 10th
of 2020 it has over a million hits
you're now entering the scene you're
only two years in the music industry
what what what's going on you know
emotionally mentally like
are you even able to fathom you know at
the pace that it's moving that's a great
question
that's like i you have no idea how crazy
i go for an idea i mean it first of all
it's the weirdest time
to become a breakthrough i was like
nominated this year for israel's
breakthrough artist of the year
you know like through galileo and i was
like all these crazy things my song was
like the most viral song in israel for a
week and
it it's hard to feel it because it's in
corona everything's behind the screen
so i have walked in the street and
sometimes i know when i walk in the
street i get people like stopping me and
liking
it which is something crazy but i'm sure
exactly the same extent is what
first of all that is crazy that's insane
but like
but what but it's not like to the extent
where i think i
fully understand the impact of the of
the song there's small moments where i
do realize i can even
i was watching the sunset like maybe two
months ago somewhere near jerusalem
and i saw these seven people walking up
like uh like passing me by i was with my
friends
and they were doing cheville island and
there were like seven people from all
over israel from a lot from the the
phone from everywhere
and five of them like went crazy like
you know they love where the days and
they i played them the song like live in
the ship like five out of seven people
just want you know it's like those those
are moments where i can really fathom it
but it's uh it's something that's hard
to understand and also it's really i'm
an independent artist i
didn't science and like i was offered to
sign
and kind of these confusing you know
like it's kind of like a reality show
you know like i finished i put this song
on it went really well i got offered all
these big like fancy
you know long-term contracts going on
it's that was
a very confusing time for me and i want
to stay independent but it's a real big
struggle like
it's hard to imagine myself like i've
i've maybe worked on seven eight songs
since finishing one of the days that
i've already recorded but i
like i'm so scared to put out a song
because you know it's like how do you i
have these expectations now you know
people have these expectations there and
thank you
for yourself thank you for the honesty i
mean i can
it's i think that's just me being honest
i'm inspired by
by your outlook and you know your
open-mindedness and i'm taking a lot
from this conversation i've done over
400 of these recordings and uh i can i
feel the energy coming out and i'm
feeling so much more energized coming
out of here than i did coming in which
which i think says everything about the
work that you're doing
hey tom thank you for being so generous
with your time before we leave
to ask you the most important question
which is not the most important question
ask many more important questions
but it is an interesting one three words
that you would use to describe yourself
i would say i'm curious and i'm
empathic and and i'm honest honesty for
me is everything i mean i hope you felt
that for me i mean
uh i i i could not agree more eitan
stay safe stay healthy i can't wait to
follow the
the album i can't wait to follow then
the upcoming songs and
wherever things take you and thank you
for making a positive impact on society
that's most of all that's uh just really
thank you
thank you for having me wow that was the
fastest 20 minutes i've had in a while
i felt like take care
[Music]
bye